ah yeah
sporting a jacket from his own clothing
line Drake headed into Nobu restaurant
in New York City and look who wasn't too
far behind getting out of the same car
hey Robin here you look beautiful
rockin a belted white dress shirt
Rihanna aka Robin looked like she had
love on the brain and was ready for an
intimate dinner with the guy who said
this about her she's somewhat I've been
in love with since I was 22 years old
all right
despite the eye roll that followed and
the little sideswipe of Drizzy's kiss on
stage
Rihanna really does just want to keep
the romance private and then I didn't
stop there Rihanna grabbed some luggage
with Drake closely behind and they both
boarded a private jet headed to Miami
where Drake has a tour stop tonight
while the Rihanna and Drake romance
might have had a public breakthrough
Teyana Taylor the breakout star of
Kanye's fake video is getting a lot of
attention I'm about the boat were
committed to the her
guess we all need to start dancing a
little more absolutely Tiana was spotted
out late last night in LA with some
comparin Tiana's news to Jennifer Beals
in Flashdance the overnight success got
a shadow from the veteran actress on
Twitter